MEG or magnetoencephalography has been used
for decades to map brain function in realtime.
It does so by measuring magnetic fields created
by electrical currents in the brain.
But conventional machines are large, heavy,
and require the patient to stay very still.
As a result, some people can’t use traditional
MEG machines like young children with epilepsy
or patients with tremors caused by neurodegenerative
diseases like Parkinson’s.
Now, researchers have created a scanner
that can be worn like a helmet.
The advance comes from new sensors
that can work at room temperature.
This sheds the bulky weight of cooling technology
required for the sensors in conventional systems.
And the helmet-mounted sensors are much closer
to the brain so the signal they can pick up
is greatly increased.
Researchers demonstrated that they could measure
brain activity while people moved naturally
in various ways, from drinking fluids
to even playing paddle ball.
However, the device’s sensors only work when
the earth’s magnetic field has been reduced
by a factor of about 50,000.
So the team developed panels consisting of
special electromagnetic coils, which help to reduce
the earth’s magnetic field around the scanner.
Researchers are now working to shrink
the helmet design for children and even babies.
They hope this technology will be to better understand
cognition and brain development--
Leading to more accurate treatments
and earlier diagnoses for all patients--
especially those with neurological,
neurodegenerative, and mental health conditions.